for more than 100 years this tahini
Factory kept its wheels turning a
family-owned business that passed down
through five generations is now heading
to the unknown I really really admire to
have here is a piece of mine to know
what I'm doing tomorrow I don't know
what I'm doing tomorrow whether I can
manage to run my factory or
not Israel keeps a tight grip on the
inputs and outputs of the Palestinian
economy in the last two decades alone
the UN says the Israeli restrictions
cost the West Bank's economy $50 billion
a large amount for a small economy under
occupation business owners say they've
been abandoned by their government left
battling an uncertain political reality
with little support and no
compensation but the Palestinian
Authority has been drowning in debt it's
not just the war but Decades of poor
economic policies 60 to 70% of the the
Palestinian Authority's budget is
dependent on the tax revenues that often
get held now the government has limited
ways to help people
financially under us pressure Israel has
released a part of the tax revenues it
owes the Palestinians but it will do
little for an already vulnerable economy
in 2023 the cost of living in the West
Bank has risen by
4.8% the unemployment reaching
unprecedented levels of 29%
even under occupation people are eager
to live a somewhat normal life this is
why Palestinian businessmen invested
millions of dollars in navis over the
past few years to advance tourism this
neighborhood so new businesses hotels
and restaurants springing up now with a
closed military checkpoint at the end of
this road it's become
deserted the closures imposed after the
war have prevented hundreds of thousands
of Palestinians living in Israel from
coming to the occupied West Bank it also
meant that Palestinian workers cannot go
to work in Israel and bring cash to the
Palestinian market sales in this
furniture shop have dropped by
80% local sales are almost non-existent
luckily for Sam bahara he's sometimes
able to sell to Palestinians living
inside
Israel for me now it's all about
survival I am not even looking towards
making profits I am just trying to
prevent my business from a total
collapse many believe the US effort to
relieve pressure on the Palestinian
Authority is meant to prevent the West
Bank from reaching a Tipping Point with
a war in Gaza daily raids and huge
uncertainty a collapsing economy will
only inflame the situation nid ibraim Al
jaaz nais the occupied West
Bank make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer